I want to continue in volume 4 and this is October the 15th 1900. This is a trial of obedience
for Louisa so I want to give you one Samuel 15 verses 22 to 24 that obedience is better
than sacrifice and I want to give you Deuteronomy 28 the blessings that come from obedience.
Louisa said, "This morning after I received communion, blessed Jesus let me hear his
voice saying, 'My daughter, this morning I feel all the necessity to be refreshed. Please
take my pains upon yourself a little bit and let me take some rest in your heart.'
Louisa said, 'Yes my good. Let me feel your pains and while I suffer in your place you
will have all the ease to be able to refresh yourself and to take some sweet rest. I only
ask of you to wait a little longer until I remain alone so that nobody may see me suffer
because it seems to me that the confessor is still here.' And Jesus said, 'What does
it matter if the priest is present? Wouldn't it be better if instead of one I had two refreshing
me?' That is you suffering and he concurring with me with the same intention.
At that moment Louisa said, 'I saw the confessor placing the intention of crucifixion and immediately
without the slightest hesitation the Lord shared with me the pains of the cross. Then
after I was in those sufferings for a little while the confessor called me to obedience.
Jesus withdrew and I tried to submit to the one who commanded me. But when in one instant
my sweet Jesus came back again wanting to subject me to the pains of the crucifixion
a second time the priest did not want it. When I would conform to Jesus that is to suffering
Jesus would come. When the priest would see that I would begin to suffer he would stop
the suffering with the obedience. So here you have a struggle between Jesus and the authority
of the church or the authority of the church with the will of God.
And so when the priest would stop it Jesus would withdraw. I would suffer a great pain
indeed on seeing Jesus withdraw but I would do as much as I could to obey. And at times
seeing the confessor present I would let them deal with it waiting to see who would win
whether obedience or our Lord. I seemed to see obedience and Jesus actually fighting.
Both powerful and both capable of facing a fight. After they fought well as I tried
to see who was winning the Queen Mother came who drawing near the priest said my son this
morning in which Jesus himself wants her to suffer would you let him do it. Otherwise
none nobody will be spared the chastisement not even in part. Because when Louisa prays
and suffers then the chastisements are reduced sometimes by one third which is absolutely
amazing. At that moment it was as if the priest was distracted in going on with the fight
and Jesus the winner subjected me to the pains again but with such vehemence and bitter spasms
that I myself do not know how I remained alive. When I thought I was dying obedience called
me again and I just barely found myself inside myself that's back to normal. Blessed Jesus
being refreshed but not yet content upon coming back wanted to repeat the crucifixion for
the third time. However arming herself with strength this time obedience won and my beloved
Jesus was defeated. In spite of this every now and then he would try who knows he might
win again. So much so that he gave me no respite and I had to say but my Lord keep still a
little bit and leave me alone. Don't you see the obedience as armed herself and will not
yield to you. So have patience. Imagine asking God to have patience. I think that's fascinating.
Have patience and if you want to repeat it the third time promise me that you will let
me die and Jesus said yes come. So I told this to the priest also and in disobedience he was
inexorable even though my sweet good was calling me saying Louisa come. I said he was calling
me but the answer was a no from the priest. What a nice obedience this is she said since
she wants to act in everything and over everything like a proper senora. She wants to meddle in
things which don't belong to her like dying. Besides how nice. Exposing a poor unhappy creature
to the dangers of dying let her touch the harbor of eternal happiness with her own hand
and then to show that she can act like a proper madam in everything by dint of the strength
she possesses she holds her back and she holds her back and makes her lie in the miserable
prison of her body. And if one asks why is all this happening first she won't answer and
then in her mute language she tells you why because I am a senora and I have power over
everything. It seems as if one wants to be at peace with this blessed obedience it takes
the patience of the saint not only that but the patience of our lord himself in other
words true heroism. Otherwise one would be in continuous frictions with her because this
is about wanting to touch the extremes. You see how the saints are tested I mean the rest
of us would go mad. So seeing that he could not win and blessed lord calmed down at the
obedience and he left me alone. He mitigated the pains I was suffering and said to me
my beloved in the pains you have suffered I wanted to have you experience the fury of
my justice by pouring it out on you a little bit. Now the fury of his justice in 1900 is
that this is when communism absolutely bursts upon the world with its totally destructive
effect to make the 20th century what Jesus himself calls the most evil century of all.
So Jesus said to her if you could see with clarity what point human beings have made
justice reach and how the fury of my justice has armed itself against them you would tremble
like a leaf and you would do nothing but pray me to pour the pains upon yourself. And then
he seemed to sustain me in my sufferings and to cheer me and he said I feel better don't
you. And Louisa said well our lord who can tell what I feel it seems to me that I have
been crushed inside of a machine. Now for that I want to give you lamentations one fourteen
B the second half of the verse verse twenty A and verse fifteen lamentations chapter one
who knows about my sorrow it talks about. And Jesus said oh Louisa said I've been crushed
inside of a machine I feel such exhaustion that if you don't infuse vigor into me I cannot
come round. And Jesus said my beloved it is necessary that you feel the pains with intensity
at least once in a while. And the amazing thing is that he says first for yourself because
as good as a piece of iron may be if it is left a long time without putting it in the
fire it always comes in contact with a little bit of dust of rust. Second for me because
if I did not unload myself on you for a long time my fury would become so ignited that
I would have no regard for the world. In other words he would end it all nor would I spare
it in the least. And if you did not take my pains upon yourself how could I maintain my
word of sparing the world chastisements at least in part because that's the gift that's
given to the victim soul. After this the confessor came to call me to obedience and I returned
inside of myself. October the 17th 1900 I have a VIP on this one. A suffering soul and
a most humble prayer make Jesus lose all strength and render him so weak as to let himself be
bound by that soul. So here the message is the power that the victim soul has over the
Lord because of the fact that she uses the passion of Jesus all the time. As my adorable
Jesus continued to come I seemed to see him in such great suffering as to her I was compassion.
Throwing myself into himself into my arms he said to me my daughter break the fury of
my justice otherwise and he didn't finish the sentence. At that moment I seemed to see divine
justice armed with swords with darts of fire so as to strike terror and also the strength with
which divine justice can act. All frightened I said how can I break your fury if I see you so
strong as to be able to annihilate heaven and earth in a simple instant he created the heavens
and the earth in a simple instant of course he can annihilate it as well. And Jesus said yet
a suffering soul and a most humble prayer make me lose all my strength and render me so weak
as to let myself be bound by that soul as she pleases. And Louisa said our Lord in what an
ugly appearance justice shows herself and Jesus added justice is not ugly because justice is
divine how can anything divine be ugly. If you see her armed like this it is because of human
beings it's because of humanity but in herself she's good and holy like my other attributes
everything in God is holy you see because there cannot even be a shadow of evil in me.
It's true that her appearance seems harsh piercing bitter but her fruits are sweet and
delicious and Matthew 7 25 says that by their fruits you will know them if the fruits are good
then the tree is good if the fruits are evil the tree is evil. So while justice may seem harsh
to us the fruits and he will talk about the fruits of justice quite a bit in these writings.
And we need to just realize and he will talk about this also as we go along that all the attributes
of God are completely equal justice equals mercy justice and mercy equal wisdom justice mercy and
wisdom equal love they're all same they're all infinite they're all divine. So October the 20th
1900 just as justice wants satisfaction for what is unjust so does love want the outpouring of
its love in other words justice and love are equal both of them are divine. This morning on
coming Louisa said my adorable Jesus made me see his attributes and he said to me my daughter
all of my attributes are in continuous attitude or relationship with humanity and all of them
demand their tribute and he added justice justice wants satisfaction for what is unjust
so does my love want the outpouring of its loving and being loved. So I want you to place
yourself inside of justice and pray and repair there and when you receive some blow have patience
to bear it but don't stay there move on into my love and give me the outpouring of love otherwise
I would remain defrauded in love as for example this time I feel all the necessity to pour out my
constrained love as if I were not allowed to do it and I would and if I were not allowed to do it
I would languish in faint as he was saying this he began to kiss me caress me and make so many
tendernesses of love that I have no words to manifest them and he wanted me to requite him saying
justice I feel the need to pour myself out with you in love so do you have the need to pour yourself
out for me isn't it true and we poured ourselves out in love to each other so what you're looking at
here is Louisa has suffered incredibly for divine justice and Jesus heals her with love love is the
great healing of the human race so October the 22nd 1900 this is about discernment
this morning I was all oppressed and with the fear that it might not be Jesus who operates in me
but the devil now she goes through this time out of number in the first 12 chapter volumes
of these writings but in spite of this I couldn't refrain from looking for him and for desiring him
however as soon as he dained to come he told me what is it that gives one the assurance
that the sun is rising if not the light which puts to flight the darkness of the night and the heat
that spreads within that light now he's trying to get her to discern his presence from the presence
of evil if anyone said that the sun is risen but in spite of this the darkness of the night appeared
even ticker and no heat could be felt what would you say it's not true that the sun has risen it's a
false claim because the effects of the sun cannot be seen this is terribly important now if the sight
of me dispels darkness from you and shows you the light of the truth making you feel the heat of my
grace why do you want to rack your brains that I am not the one who operates in you in other words
you have the proof god is light one john one five jesus is the light of the world john eight twelve
matthew seven twenty you can tell them by their fruits okay so after this then
louisa says i add this because obedience wants it that the other day i was thinking
if the many chastisements about which i wrote in these books should really occur
who would have the heart to be the spectator of them and blessed lord may be understand with clarity
this is very very important that some of them will occur while i'm still on the earth now louisa
died in 1947 so some of the stuff was going to happen during her lifetime some after my death
and some will be spared in part so i was a little relieved thinking that i will not have to see them
all okay and and you see amos three seven or eight says that the lord never does anything without
telling his prophets first the lord is continuously telling us about what will happen to the earth
if we continue sinning and what will happen when we repent the whole bible is full of that and the
whole history the church is full of it as well so louisa continues here is lady obedience that
means the priests representing the church made satisfied now after she had begun to frown at me
and to send out laments and reprimands in other words unreasonable obedience it seems that this
blessed young lady is in no way wants to adapt herself to the human reason she does not want to
get involved in any circumstance on the contrary it seems that she has no reason at all she's quite
a pain in the neck which is fantastic to have louisa say that it just shows you that while the saints
will obey and will live according to the challenges that the god has given them they still feel like
the rest of us but i think is wonderful but still quite a pain in the neck having to deal with
someone who does not have reason in order to get along a little it's necessary to lose one's own
reason because the young lady keeps boasting i have no human reason therefore i do not know how
to adapt myself to the human way my reason is divine and for one who wants to live in peace with
me it's absolutely necessary that she lose hers in order to acquire mine i want to give you eyes i
have 55 versus 8 to 10 my thoughts are not your thoughts my ways are not your ways my ways are
as different from yours as the heavens are from the earth so louisa said this is how well this young
lady reasons what can one say it's better to keep silent because in one way or another she always
wants to be right and she glories in giving you all the wrong so louisa is letting us know very
clearly how costly these obediencees from the priest really are and how much against her own will
it is and so you can see that through obedience the lord is conquering louisa's will so that
he will be able to let the divine will take over so october the 23rd 1900 is about love i've said
many times that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love this morning after i received
communion my adorable jesus made me see the confessor who is placing the intention of having me
suffer the crucifixion i felt my poor nature reluctant not because i didn't want to suffer but
for other reasons that i can't describe here but jesus is though lamenting about me said to father
she doesn't want to submit herself i was moved at his lament the the priest renewed the command
and i submitted myself so notice that you are always completely free the lord will never override
your free will ever ever he wants that when we get to heaven it has been our own decision
to go there it's been our own decision to do god's will and to cooperate with him and everything
so louisa said after i suffered a little since i saw that the priest was present the lord said
my beloved here is the symbol of the most holy trinity myself the priest and you
from eternity my love has never been alone but always united in perfect and reciprocal union
with the divine persons because true love never remains alone but produces other loves and delights
in being loved back that's proverbs 8 31 the lord delights to be with the children of men
so he delights in being loved back by the loves which he has produced and if it is alone either it is
not of the nature of divine love it's only apparent if you knew how much i delight in and enjoy
being able to continue that love in souls which rained from eternity and reigns still now in the
most holy trinity this john 15 9 as the father has loved me so i have loved you and then he at the
end he says so you must love one another you also have jeremaia 31 3 i have loved you with an everlasting
love and i am constant in my affection for you this is also why i say to you that i want the
consensus of the intention of the priest united with me to be able to continue this love more
perfectly which is a symbol of the most holy trinity he wants everything in threes and we'll
hear much more about this as we go on in these writings uh so october the 29th 1900
again we're talking about love this there's a vip on this one the most essential
and necessary thing in a soul is charity that's divine love and it's agape in greek
after going through a few days of privation and of silence this morning
as blessed jesus came i said it shows that my state is no longer your will and he said yes yes
rise and come into my arms he said at these words i forgot about the painful state of the last few
days and i ran into his arms and since i could see his side was open i said my beloved you have not
admitted me to drink from your side for some time i pray you to admit me to it today and jesus said
my beloved please drink as much as you like and satiate yourself who can say my contentment and
what a vidity i placed my mouth at to drink from the divine fount okay after i drank my fill to the
point of having no more room to contain even just one more drop i'd attached myself and jesus said
have you sat satiated yourself if you haven't keep drinking i don't mind and louisa said satiated no
because the more one drinks of this font the more one one's thirst increases but since i am very
limited i'm incapable of taking more so i want to give you isiah 55 verses one to three common drink
is the the invitation there john seven thirty seven to thirty nine if you truly believe in me come
and drink and out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water i want to give you two
quarantines four verses 10 to 11 so after this i saw other people with jesus louisa said and he said
the most essential and necessary thing in the soul is charity as one john four seven to 17 god
is love and also one quarantines 13 13 the greatest of these is love one quarantines 14
one uh you must want love more than anything else if there's no charity in the soul it happens
it's the same as with those families or kingdoms that have no rulers everything's upset and the
most beautiful things remain obscure there's no harmony uh someone to do one thing some another
the same happens in the soul uh in which uh divine love does not reign everything is in disorder
just like society is today the most beautiful virtue uh virtues do not harmonize among themselves
and this is why charity is always called the queen because she rules and orders and
disposes everything now we're going to hear an awful lot more about that as we go on in these
writings october the 31st 1900 this is about blessed mother
the celestial mother helps louisa to disarm justice okay as i was in my usual state i felt
myself outside of myself and i found the queen mother as she saw me she began to speak about
justice and how justice is about to clash with all its fury against humanity
she said many things about this and i don't have the words to express them
in the meantime i could see the whole of heaven filled with points of swords against the world
and then she added my daughter you have disarmed divine justice many times
contenting yourself with receiving its blows upon yourself
now that you see that divine justice is at the summit of its fury do not lose heart but be courageous
with the heart full of holy fortitude now this fortitude is the steel girders for your soul
enter into this justice and disarm it do not be afraid of the swords the fire or anything else
that you may encounter in order to obtain the intent if you see yourself wounded beaten burned
rejected don't draw back rather let this be a spur for you to move on see so that you may do this
i myself have come to help you by bringing you a special garment
as your soul wears it you will acquire courage and fortitude so that you will fear nothing
so having said this from within her mantle she pulled out a garment woven of gold
streaked with various colors and she clothed it my soul now it seems to me i can't prove it
but it seems to me that our blessed mother is clothing louisa with her own virtues and her own
merits then she gave me her son telling me and now as a pledge of my love i place my dearest son
in your custody so it would make sense that with a loan of blessed mothers virtues and graces
that then she looks after jesus himself i place my dearest son in your custom
custody that you may keep him love him and content him in everything try to act in my stead
in other words be a mother to him now we've met this already in volume two
that jesus had asked louisa to be another earthly mother for him
so here's blessed mother saying it to her try and act in my stead try and do what i would do
so that he finds all his contentment in you the discontent that all the others will give him
may not cause him so much pain so the next long paragraph is about resignation to the divine will
you see we're on a journey and we don't succeed in surrendering our wills very easily it's a big
struggle you may think you've done it and then you discover you've been doing your own will for
hours so it's it's a struggle it's a journey and the very first stage of that major journey is true
deep humble loving resignation to the divine will and that's what we're going to be talking about
louisa said who can say how happy and strengthened i was clued it with that garment and with the
loving pledge in my arms as the pledge of blessed mother greater happiness i could certainly not
desire then the queen mother disappeared and i remained with my sweet jesus we went around the
earth a little bit and among the many encounters we met a soul who was a prey to despair having
compassion for that soul we drew near her and jesus wanted me to speak to her to make her understand
the evil that is the evil of suicide that she was doing through a light which is infused knowledge
which jesus himself infused into me i said to her the most solitary and efficacious medicine
in the saddest encounters of life is resignation it's step one by despairing instead of taking the
medicine you are taking the poison with which to kill your soul let's mortal sin
don't you know that the most appropriate remedy for all evils the main thing that renders us noble
divinizes us makes us similar to our lord and has the power of converting the very bitterness
into sweetness is resignation so resignation is the thing that actually changes us it doesn't change
god but it does change us jesus says it has the power of changing the very bitterness we're going
through into sweetness what was the life of jesus fawn earth if not continuing to do the will of the
father now i'd have to give you a complete summary of john's gospel for that but i'm only going to
give you john 14 31 i want the world to know that i love the father therefore i do exactly what my
father tells me and while he was on earth he was united with the father in heaven it is the same
for a resigned soul while living on the earth her heart and her will are united with god in heaven
want to give you romans 828 there that nothing can separate us from christ nothing at all
except our own will of course can there be anything more dear and desirable than this
louise asks as those stirred that soul began to cam herself and jesus and i together withdrew
in other words once grace has been given then it's up to the individual to take the grace
and to act with it may everything be for the glory of god and we won't hear any more about that soul
of course so november the second 1900 here we have that union with god is the source of happiness
now as we go on in these writings we start with union with god being the source of happiness the
divine will is happiness the divine will is the operating part of the blessed Trinity the source
of all life all happiness all be attitude so november the second 1900 this morning louise said
i feel all oppressed and afflicted with the addition that blessed jesus was not making himself
seen then after much waiting he came out from within my interior because he's there all the time
so i want to give you one Corinthians 3 16 for that no you not that you are the temple of the living
god and that the spirit of god dwells in you so he came out from within my interior opening his
heart to me he placed me inside his heart telling me remain inside of me only there will you find
true peace and true contentment sam 131 because nothing penetrates into me which does not belong
to peace and contentment okay Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god
one who dwells in me does nothing but swim in the sea of all contentment i want to give you
john 14 20 to 21 and Philippians 4 7 the peace that passes all understanding
while by going outside of me even the soul even if the soul did not bother about anything at the
mere sight of the offenses they give me that human beings give me and how humanity grieves me
she already comes to participate in those afflictions and she remains troubled
in other words we see louisa still at this point in volume four allowing herself to get upset
by what she sees is going wrong in the world she's got to be able to look at it and she will come to
that to look at it peacefully and still do the reparation so therefore every once in a while
would you forget everything enter into me and enjoy the peace and happiness now we call that
contemplative prayer going into the depth of that silence then go out and do for me then go out
and do for me the office of my repairer so having said this he disappeared
november the eighth 1900 this one is about obedience okay and i just want to give you as an introduction
once an order is given the human rebellion will be shown up and must be dealt with so obedience
exposes our ego and destroys it let me give you an example
many years ago i used to do a bit of babysitting and if the mother said on leaving the house
don't touch the biscuits there was only one issue for the whole evening and it was biscuits
but if the mother had said nothing the rebellion wouldn't have been shown up
god said adam and eve don't touch that particular fruit in the garden of eden it was the only
thing they wanted to touch and that is what actually illustrates the rebellion inside of us and that's why
obedience actually deals with that rebellion that is in the very warp and wolf of our being
i mean one of the things that you can see frequently on the roads in arland
is people parking on double yellow lines the double yellow line says this is the place where
you don't park but if people park there they're saying i can park wherever i like
there's absolute rebellion to a law telling them that you may not do it there
i think the best thing i've ever seen was a car parked out on double yellow lines outside of a
police station so continuing with these usual delays louisa said uh i was feeling all the
weight of his privation when all of a sudden jesus came i don't know why he posed me this question
would you be able to tell me why obedience is so glorified that's one samuel 15 versus 20 to 24
and receives such honor as to imprint the divine image on the soul romans 8 21
all confused i didn't know what to answer now she's been through this terrible trial of obedience
she doesn't know how to answer it but through an intellectual light that he sent to me that's
infused knowledge jesus answered it himself and since it was through this infused knowledge and not
words i don't have the terms to express it however obedience wants me to try and see if i could manage
to write something i believe i'll only speak nonsense on the right things which do not really
go together but i place all my faith in obedience especially since these are things that regard her
directly and so i'm going to try she says it seemed to me that jesus was saying obedience is so
glorified because she has the power of unveiling the human passions from their very roots and right
from the very beginning of our lives as well it's wonderful to see children saying one of the first
things they say is no no they suddenly discover that they have a free will and they're not going to
surrender to everything and so obedience has the power of unveiling the human passions from their
very roots she that is obedience destroys in the soul everything which is earthly and material
that's why it's so costly to us and to her great honor she gives back to the soul her original state
that is pre-fall that is the way she was created by god in her original justice
before being cast out of the terrestrial Eden so she's obedience will bring you back to the state
that adam was in before the fall which is quite incredible and you understand therefore why
louisa was exercised so much in obedience and in this sublime state the soul feels
strongly drawn to everything that is good she feels all that is good holy and perfect is
inborn within herself only when she goes back to that state though and this is very important for
us because the lord is trying to bring us all back to that original state to pick up from where
adam left off and she feels the greatest horror at even the shadow of evil at this point
with this happy nature received from the most experienced hand of obedience the soul no longer
finds difficulty in executing commands received more so since the one who commands must always
command what is good of course that's the important thing if someone commands you to do evil of course
it's not the obedience we're talking about we're talking about obedience that leads to the fullness
of the divine will and here's how obedience knows how to imprint well the divine image
not only this but she changes human nature into divine so you can see why louisa is being so
severely exercised because the lord wants to bring her up onto this divine level where she will live
in the divine will and not live down at the human level at all he wants to make her the great eagle
after himself this is where obedience changes the human nature into divine because just as god
is good holy and most perfect he tends to all that is good and greatly hates evil so does obedience
have the power of divinizing human nature and of making it acquire the divine qualities
that's why the church right from the very beginning of its history
had such a strong thing about men and women going into communities and taking vows of obedience and
vows of poverty and vows of chastity to bring the church back to this original state
and the more the soul lets herself be handled by this most experienced hand
the more of the divine she acquires destroying her own being is what my book says you can't destroy
your own being destroying her ego and this is why she's so glorified and honored so much so that I
myself submitted to her that's I myself submitted to obedience such your john 14 31 again and was
honored and glorified by this and through her I gave back honor and glory to all of my children
which they had lost through disobedience now when you study the Old Testament deeply you find that
the whole thing is a struggle between the divine will and the human will and that the lord says to
his people over and over and over again in book after book after book I only asked you to listen
to my word and to obey my word I did not ask for all the sacrifices I did not ask for all the
stuff that you're doing I only asked for obedience so the last little paragraph here is this is more
or less what I've been able to manifest the rest I feel inside of my mind but I lack the words
because the height and the concept of this virtue is such that my poor human language is unable to
adapt itself so she'll say more later on because she'll be forced to it November the 10th 1900
this is about love and trust and something which is desperately important for nowadays
and that is to trust God beyond reason as he can Jesus continued not to come Louisa said I felt
immersed in the greatest bitterness my soul was tortured in a thousand ways then I felt as though
a shadow was near me and I heard the voice of my adorable Jesus though I couldn't see him saying
to me the most perfect love is in the true trust that one must have in the loved object to love
somebody and not trust them is a contradiction in terms we trust people that we truly love
and we love people that we truly trust their two sides of the one relationship
and if it should appear that the object one loves is lost then more than ever is the time to prove
this living trust this is the easiest means to take possession of what one ardently loves
having said this both shadow and voice disappeared and who could say the pain I felt in not having
my beloved good the Sam 63 so November the 11th we're talking about going out of the divine will
I'm part of the results of going out of the divine will it seems that the blessed Lord
wants to exercise me in patience he has no compassion either for my tears or for my most sorrowful
state without him I see myself immersed in the greatest miseries I believe that there's no soul
more wicked than mine now louisa isn't actually telling the truth there she just is associating her
weakness and miseries with wickedness even though when I am with Jesus I see myself bad more than
ever that's because they human and the divine have an infinite distance between the two
however since I am with him who possesses all goods my soul finds the remedy for all evils
but when I don't have him everything is over for me there's no more remedy for my miseries
a lot is more I am oppressed by the thought that my state is no longer his will and not being in
his will I seem to be outside of the center and many times I think of how to go out of this divine will
so not being with these dispositions now sorry now being with these dispositions
I felt Jesus behind my shoulder saying to me you are tired aren't you and louisa said yes lord I
feel quite tired and he continued am I daughter do not go out of my will because by going out of my
will you come to lose the knowledge of me that's extremely important the more people move away
from God's will the less they understand him the more they come into God's will the more they
understand him and of course not knowing me you come to lose the knowledge of yourself
I need to give you hosea four six there and that is that for lack of knowledge of God the people
perish in fact only in the reflections of the light one can distinguish distinguish with clarity
whether there is gold or mud that's sam 36 verse nine lord only in your light can we actually see
light if everything is darkness objects can easily be confused now the light is my will one john
one five this is a very important stage we've reached because from here on in the divine will
will simply be called the light okay because God is light and the divine will is the essence of God
so the light is my will which gives you the knowledge of me and in the reflections of this light
you come to know who you are we only come to know our sinfulness by looking at the holiness of God
we only can see our true selfishness by looking at the love of God we can see our terrible injustices
by looking at the justice of God and so on and so on now the light of my will which gives you the
knowledge of me and in the reflections of this light you come to know who you are and in seeing
your weakness your pure nothingness you cling to my arms and united with me you live with me in heaven
but if you want to go out of my will first you will come to lose true humility and then you will
come to live on the earth that means you become more earthy and you would be forced to feel the
earthly weight to moan and to sigh like all the other unfortuners who live outside of my will
a sam 63 verse eight and having said this he withdrew without even letting himself be seen
and she said you can't imagine the torment of my soul so November the 13th 1900
and Louisa sees the many human miseries the degradation and stripping of the church and the very degrading
of priests this is a very important message because it applies to now to the crisis that's in the
church so I want to give you Isaiah 64 10 and Amos 3 7 the Lord speaking to the prophets ahead of time
after going through several days of most bitter privation having received holy communion
I saw three children within my interior their beauty and equality was such that all three of
them seem to be born of the same labor my soul was surprised and stupefied in seeing so much beauty
and closed in the circle of my miserable interior and my stupefaction increased even more when I
saw that these three children seemed to have many ropes of gold in their hands and with these they
bound themselves completely to me and my heart to them now that brings you back to volume one
where she begins to see the blessed Trinity and they begin to bind her to themselves
then afterwards as if one was taking his place they began to discuss among themselves
as if each one was taking his place they began to discuss among themselves I couldn't understand
and I cannot find the words to repeat their most high language I can only say that in the
twinkling of an eye I saw the many miseries the degradation and stripping of the church and the
very degrading of priests who instead of being the light of people are darkness okay now like
all prophecies there's more than one layer there for example in the Soviet takeover in Russia and
the satellite states of Russia the church was terribly degraded and there are millions of martyrs
so there's that aspect of it but the second aspect of it is now with the apostasy that's in the church
that priests instead of being a light some of them are darkness all embittered by this site I said
most holy god give peace to the church let her be given back what they have taken away from her
and do not allow evil to laugh behind the back of the good and as I was saying this they said
these are incomprehensible mysteries of god and having said this they disappeared so I want to
give you Romans 11 33 to 36 and Isaiah 40 verse 13 so November 14 1900 the queen mother refreshes
Jesus and Louisa is taken to purgatory this morning oncoming my adorable Jesus transported me outside
of myself and asked me for a refreshment for his pains now the refreshment is suffering for the
sake of souls and holding back divine justice having nothing I said most sweet love if the queen
mother was here she could refresh you with her milk but as for myself I have nothing but miseries
that's john 15 five at that moment the most holy queen came and immediately I said to her
Jesus feels the necessity of a refreshment give him some of your sweet milk for he will be refreshed
so our dearest mother gave him her milk and my beloved Jesus was all refreshed
then turning to me he said I feel cheered you too draw close to my lips and drink part of that
milk which I received from my mother so that we both may be refreshed now you need to know that
milk represents life that you draw life from the other one okay and when children put their
mouths to their mother's breasts what they are actually doing is drawing life they're not just
drawing a liquid so Louisa did this but who can tell the power of that milk that came out boiling
hot from Jesus and he had so much of it that it seemed an immense fount such that even if all
men should drink of it all men should drink of it it wouldn't decrease anything after this we went
round the earth a little and at some place it seemed to be people sitting at a little table saying
there will be war in Europe that is 1914 to 1918 of course as I say there are different layers for
these so it might be the second world war as well 1939 to 45 and while it's more sorrowful
it will be caused by relatives Jesus was listening but he didn't say anything on that regard and
therefore I do not know for sure whether there will be or not since human judgments are mutable
and what they say today they deny tomorrow then he transported me inside of a garden
in which arose an immense building like a monastery populated by so many people that it was difficult
to count them that's usually an image of the church he's seeing at the sight of these people
my adorable Jesus turned his back on the he clung against me with all of himself leaning his head
on my shoulder close to my neck and he said to me my beloved don't let me see them otherwise I would
suffer greatly as the condition of the church today so I too clasped him Louisa said and drawing near
one of those souls I said tell me at least who are you and she answered we are all purging souls
okay and our liberation is bound to the satisfaction of those pious legacies
which we have left to our successors and since they're not satisfied we are forced to stay here
away from our God what pain this is for us so that great garden then that she sees is purgatory
it is the suffering church
and so what they're saying is that before they died they left money for their
relatives to offer masses and suffrage for them and since the masses weren't offered
they are still in purgatory we can experience what pain this is for us they said to her
because God becomes for us a necessary being whom we cannot do without just as Louisa knows
we experience a continuous death which martyrs us in the most ruthless way
and if we do not die it's because our soul is not subject to this so sorrowful as we are
being without an object that forms our whole life we implore God to make mortals experience
a minimum of our pains by depriving them of what is necessary for the preservation of
more of corporal life that they may learn at their own expense how painful it is to be without what
is absolutely necessary now what you're saying here reading there is absolutely incredible
that because human beings will not do the suffragers for the souls in purgatory and get them relieved
the souls in purgatory then ask God to send us chastisement so that we will know what the pain
of being without God is actually like in other words they send purgatory to the earth absolutely
amazing so after this the Lord carried me somewhere else and i feeling compassion for these souls said
how come my good Jesus that you turned your face away from these blessed souls who so much
longed for you while it would have been enough that you would let yourself be seen for those souls
to be freed of the pains and be beatified he said oh my daughter if i had shown myself to them
since they are not completely purged they could not have stood in my presence and instead of flinging
themselves into my arms confused they would have drawn back and i would have done nothing but
increased their martyrdom and mine this is why i did so and having said that he disappeared
so i want to give you Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God
so we'll stop there for this particular session